herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren
diese woche fand hier in zürich das
world web forum statt
vordenker der digitalwirtschaft namhafte
politiker und unternehmer trafen sich um
gemeinsam über das motto end of nations
nachzudenken das ende des
nationalstaates
tatsächlich kennt das internet ja keine
staatsgrenzen und mächtige konzerne wie
google oder facebook entziehen sich
gerne der staatlichen regulierung etwa
wenn es um datenschutz oder um
wettbewerbsrecht geht fragt sich also
wie kann die politik den großen
internetkonzernen die stirn bieten und
wie können wir sie und ich die digitale
zukunft demokratisch mitgestalten
darüber spreche ich heute mit zwei
ausgewiesenen expertin jeanette hofmann
ist professorin für internetpolitik in
berlin und hat eine charta für digitale
grundrechte mit initiiert viktor mayer
schönberger ist professor am oxford
internet institute und eine renommierte
experte wenn es um die macht von daten
gibt herzlich willkommen in beiden ja
wir sehen hier die sie aus der großen
digital konzerne apple google facebook
und amazon sind das die könige des
internetzeitalters frau hoffnung
nein das würde ich so nicht sagen dass
es sich um die könige handelt ich glaube
auch gar nicht dass die diagnose dass
wir das ende des nationalstaats erreicht
haben dass diese diagnose stimmt die
entwicklung ist viel uneinheitlicher als
dieser titel der konferenz suggeriert
auf der einen seite ist es natürlich so
dass wir auch auf der individuellen und
wirtschaftlichen ebene heute
transnational agieren aber auf der
anderen seite kann man schon beobachten
dass die nationalstaaten und auch die eu
in den letzten jahren immer stärker
dafür gesorgt hat dass nationale gesetze
auch geltung haben im internet
trotzdem haben diese firmen eine große
8 welche art von macht kumuliert sich
denn da herr mayer schönberger nun zum
einen die ganze klassische macht zu
machen fiel um so zu machen viel
gewinnen und haben damit viel geld und
wer viel geld hat hat jedenfalls in
amerika viele einfluss auf die politik
das sieht man nicht nur in der jetzigen
regierung sondern auch in den
regierungen davor
zum anderen geben sie vielen menschen
arbeit amazon bietet über 300.000
menschen weltweit einen arbeitsplatz das
ist für viele regierungen und für viele
gesellschaften ein wichtiger arbeitgeber
auch da gibt es macht heraus und diese
unternehmen haben im vergleich zu
anderen konventionellen unternehmen
viele taten viele informationen und
daraus ergibt sich informationelle macht
darüber werden wir sprechen was das
genau bedeutet und was die daten wert
sind mich würde interessieren was das
gesellschaftlich mit uns macht eine
weiche formen der macht was diese firmen
diese was google facebook in unseren
köpfen ausgelöst habe in den letzten
jahren also sie habe das digitale hat
natürlich einfluss auf unser verhalten
wenn man heute durch städte geht und
sieht wie die leute vollkommen versunken
auf ihr telefon gucken und links und
rechts nichts mehr wahrnehmen
dann kann man schon spüren diese enorme
faszination die von den verbunden sein
mit anderen aber auch mit anderen
objekten aus geht ja unsere orientierung
haben sich grundsätzlich verändert und
wir sehen zum beispiel auch dass bei
jugendlichen heute man die nur noch
schwer vor die tür bekommt weil die
eigentlich den ganzen tag am computer
sein und spielen wollen
also man kann beobachten dass sich
unsere orientierungen quer durch die
generationen verändern durch das
digitale darüber werden wir auch noch
sprechen nach über dieses paradox mann
ist vernetzt trotzdem sind so ein
bisschen isoliert vor ihren bildschirmen
das beobachten wir jetzt wie gesagt
diese woche fahren dieses world web
forum statt wo sich die digitalen
vordenker in zürich getroffen haben
und das motto der slogan war end of
nations und wir haben damals wissen
herumgefragt und mit namhaften personen
gesprochen was denn das eigentlich
heißen könnte und was hinter diesem
provokativen titel stecken könnte also
eine nation ist eine gute provokation
als these um 2000 leute an eine
konferenz zu holen
initiiert auch eine diskussion
ich glaube natürlich überhaupt nicht
daran da bin ich wirklich daran am
schluss bei johann schneider rahmen der
heute auch gesagt hat selbstverständlich
braucht es die normandy regulierungen
die rahmen eines einer nation
ich finde es spannend diese diese diese
suggestion dass die nations wenn sie an
geografischen grenzen gemessen sind das
die nicht mehr das die zukunft sein
sollten sondern ist und welche facebook
oder das werde auch immer ich finde das
spannend
aber ich bin überzeugt das wird nicht
passieren im titel steckt viel drama
aber dahinter steckt ein phänomen
nationen tun sich zunehmend schwerer
damit komplexe probleme zu lösen zum
beispiel das klimaproblem die
flüchtlingsfrage den konflikt um die
natürlichen ressourcen
hier können die unternehmer und
investoren in die bresche springen und
helfen
es wird die nations in open spirit geben
hoffentlich und dann sind die nation ist
immer noch miteinander im wettbewerb und
wettbewerb spielt ist der fortschritt am
besten gesichert es gibt
mehr parallelstrukturen wo einerseits
die etablierten ihrer schieren nach wie
vor bestand haben ein stück weit gewisse
funktionen erfüllen genauso wie
nationalstaaten gewisse funktionen
erfüllen aber gleichzeitig gibt es immer
mehr auch dank der digitalisierung
stores möglichkeiten communitys zu
bilden netzwerke zu bilden die völlig
losgelöst ein stück weit von diesem
märchen und von den nationalstaaten sind
und diese parallel diese zweigleisigkeit
das ist was ich unter der frage end of
nations verstehe natürlich es ist jetzt
extrem formuliert aber ich glaube darauf
zielt dass ein stück weiter auf diese
tendenz je mehr globalisierung sie haben
bei dienstleistungen durch das internet
möglicherweise stärker wird das
bedürfnis auch wieder irgendwo zu etwas
zu gehören ist ja nicht zuletzt was wir
in den letzten paar jahren gesehen haben
also eine art zur rückbesinnung auf
nationalitäten ja im letzten statement
kommt gut diese spannung zum vorschein
zwischen der tendenz zur globalisierung
starten überschreibt und grenzen
überschreiten aber auch wieder die
sehnsucht nach dem lokalen und
nationalen ist dass diese dieser slogan
end of nations wirklich nur provokation
wie die meisten gesagt haben nein das
glaube ich nicht dass es nur provokation
ist ich glaube wir dürfen nicht
vergessen dass der nationalstaat selbst
nur ein konstrukt einer bestimmten zeit
ist vor 2000 jahren gab es keinen
nationalstaat der nationalstaat ist ein
konstrukt der letzten 500 jahre um ein
ganz bestimmtes problem um eine ganz
bestimmte aufgabe vielleicht zu lösen so
weiter das in der zukunft tun kann
weiter bestand haben so weiter das nicht
tun kann wird durch andere strukturen
supranationaler transnationaler oder
auch ganz dezentraler strukturen ersetzt
werden was wichtig ist für uns zu
verstehen alles ist veränderung
das bedeutet dass auch der nationalstaat
nicht in stein gemeißelt und ihre
prognose wird eher unwichtiger absolut
wird eher unwichtiger ganz klar um weil
der nationalstaat nicht in der lage ist
die komplexen grenzüberschreitenden
probleme zu lösen
und gleichzeitig rück zu binden auf das
regionale und das lokale der menschen
der steht zwischen zwei stühlen der
nationalstaat und deswegen wird er
weniger wichtig hoffmann ich würde sagen
wir können beobachten dass wie victor
eben sagte bei problemstellungen die
grenzüberschreitend sind das ist etwa
die umweltpolitik das ist die
finanzpolitik und das ist auch das
digitale dass da der nationalstaat nur
ein akteur unter mehreren lässt aber was
beispielsweise strafverfolgung anbelangt
da haben wir eine kooperation zwischen
nationalstaaten aber der nationalstaat
als solcher wird ganz sicher nicht
unwichtiger insofern muss man immer
fragen um welches politikfeld es gerade
geht um aussagen darüber treffen zu
können ob das ist nationalstaat
wichtiger oder unwichtiger wird
aber wenn man sich so die grundbegriffe
der politischen philosophie anschaut
souveränität der nationalstaaten
rechtsstaat demokratie da passieren
schon in der version jahre würde ich
auch sagen auch unser verständnis von
demokratie wird sich ganz sicher ändern
weil wir eine gewisse entkopplung sehen
von selbstbestimmung individueller und
kollektiver art und dem territorial
start mit denen wir das frühjahr und
rennfahrer untrennbar verbunden haben da
können wir sehen dass das nicht mehr
ganz übereinstimmt und wir sehen das
auch bei dem wunsch der schotten
unabhängig zu werden oder bei dem wunsch
der katalanen
das sind bedürfnisse neue
identifikations körper und gefäße zu
finden weil die menschen glauben oder
den eindruck haben dass der
nationalstaat ihre bedürfnisse nicht
mehr in der firma fühlen kann wie er sie
bisher erfüllt hat und dann
transnationalen im internationalen
bereich machen wir das gleiche
neben den europäischen gerichtshof der
uns den rechtsstaat auf eine höhere
ebene hebt und damit verhindert dass
einzelne mitgliedstaaten der
europäischen union ihren rechtsstaat
untergraben können das ist alles gut
ich würde allerdings sagen dass wir
diese art von spannungen zwischen
nationaler souveränität und regionaler
autonomie eigentlich durchweg erlebt
haben die sind schon in die entstehung
des nationalstaats eingebunden das sind
ja blutige prozesse gewesen der
unterwerfung von menschen der
homogenisierung von sprache man sieht in
der schweiz ist es zu dieser art von
integration nie gekommen
es gibt immer noch mehrere sprachen
nebeneinander und das ist immer wieder
aufgebrochen
hier würde ich sagen das sind
entwicklungen die haben nichts mit dem
internet zu tun oder nicht
notwendigerweise genau die haben mit der
globalisierung zu tun mit dingen die
sonst passieren ich ja aber vielleicht
hilft das internet schon der benedikt
anderson hat ein wunderbares buch über
der nationalstaat gestiegenem agent
community ist der franke tätige machen
also eine eine gemeinschaft die man sich
sozusagen ein bildet dann ist der
nationalstaat und bei dieser einbildung
hilft natürlich das internet schon und
es hilft aber auch bei der zerstörung
dieser einbildung weil es uns erlaubt
auch uns einfach zu informieren ohne ein
informationsmonopol des nationalen also
ich finde es witzig dass du gerade
darauf zu sprechen kommt weil ich
verwende dieses beispiel oder dieses
buch auch immer aber eigentlich um zu
sagen dass medien immer schon eine
grundlegende rolle gespielt haben in der
formierung größerer gruppen die also
über das hinausgehen was man sehen kann
alles was größer als ein dorf ist wo man
jeden kann kennt das muss medial
vermittelt werden weil sonst gar keine
gemeinschaft entstehen kann
und wichtig für den nationalstaat sind
die klassischen medien gewesen zeitungen
als eines der ersten massenprodukte
radio und dann auch fernsehen
aber genau diese konstellation des
nationalen die auf die mit massenmedien
zusammenhängt die zerfällt jetzt jetzt
müssen wir bevor wir noch weiter darüber
diskutieren erst mal gucken was das für
geschäftsmodelle sind hinter diesen
sozialen medien die jetzt diese
communitys diese gemeinschaften bilden
so etwas
wie facebook und so und erstmal muss man
sich klar machen womit man da bezahlt
also wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel bei
google mail konto habe gmail oder
whatsapp benutzer oder facebook dann
zahl ich da sagen sie mit mit meinen
daten das ist ja eigentlich vermeintlich
gratis ich kriege datendienst und ich
kann facebook nutzen denke ich möchte
sie nicht sagen aber ich zahle mit
meinen daten
warum sind denn die daten eigentlich so
wertvoll für diese firmen und was machen
sie damit also zum einen meine
studentinnen und studenten glauben nicht
dass sie das google mail account
kostenlos bekommen oder ihre facebook
bekannt kostenlos bekommen
die wissen ganz genau das ist eine
leistung und dafür gibt es eine
gegenleistung und die gegenleistung sind
ihre daten die gegenleistung sind die
persönlichen informationen die sie für
sich preisgeben für meine studenten
entstanden ist nur interessant ob diese
leistung gegenleistung in balance
herrscht und das denken sie bei google
oder bei facebook viele davon jedenfalls
das wäre der fall was machen google und
facebook mit diesen daten nun sie
verbessern ihr produkt zu verbessern
ihre dienstleistung und versuchen damit
beispielsweise werbebotschaften sehr
viel zielgerichteter auf ein publikum
hin zu bringen
das ist ja im interesse der werbung die
dümmste werbung ist die die gleiche
botschaft dann sehr viele menschen
stände das gießkannenprinzip zu einem
antiken wurde mir nachdem ich eine reise
gebucht habe reiseinformationen und
reiseprospekte zuzusenden
das wäre vollkommen falsch und mit den
daten versuchen diese unternehmen ihre
produkte zu verbessern
also dass schon eindrücklich wenn man
sich die zahlen anschauen google und
facebook gehören 80 prozent der
weltweiten werbeeinnahmen im internet 80
prozent diesen beiden firmen und 79 97
prozent des umsatzes macht facebook mit
werbung bei google sind es ungefähr 88
also zusammenfallen
das spiel ja aber noch viel spannender
ist wenn sich in dem gesamten werbe top
vergleichen
von den gesamten werbeeinnahmen in den
industrieländern geht etwa 20 prozent an
google
also das ist signifikant aber das
bedeutet vor allem dass sich die
werbeeinnahmen verschoben haben weg von
den klassischen medien den zeitungen dem
fernsehen hin zu google
das bedeutet für die zeitungen dass sie
weniger einnahmen haben für google dass
sie viel geld haben genau
und irgendwie ist dieses daten tracking
wie man das nennt das leben permanent
ausspioniert werden in der digitalen
mehr das scheint eben für viele gar kein
problem mehr zu sein entweder man weiß
es nicht so genau oder man rechnet
benefit auf und denkt sich okay ich habe
diesen nutzen das ist für mich okay hat
sich das in den letzten jahren
jahrzehnten verschoben und wissen dieses
bewusstsein in sachen datenschutz
wir sagen ja immer dass wenn man für ein
produkt oder eine dienstleistung nicht
zahlt ist man selbst das produkt das
produkt insofern als dass man selber das
eigene verhalten quasi in wert gesetzt
wird damit man das dann an
werbetreibende diese informationen
weitergeben kann
wir als nutzerinnen und nutzer können
nicht wissen was langfristig mit unseren
daten passiert und das ist auch ein
bisschen das problem das ist ja eine
recht neue entwicklung die erst seit den
frühen 2000er jahren eingesetzt hat
dieses geschäftsmodell und die folgen
für uns individuell aber auch kollektiv
sind so abstrakt dass wir die in unser
verhalten haben noch nicht einbauen
können wir können uns faktisch noch
nicht vorstellen welche folgen das für
uns haben wird auch weil diese folgen
noch nicht spürbar sind wir kennen die
auch zum teil noch nicht und daher rührt
auch meine ich dass er sorglose
verhalten wenn man mit leuten
individuell spricht sagen sie schon dass
sie sich darüber sorgen machen
jedenfalls in deutschland ist das der
fall in den usa und vermutlich auch in
großbritannien eher weniger in der
schweiz vielleicht auch eher wie in
deutschland ein wenig mehr aber wirklich
sich genau vorstellen was das für unsere
zukunft auch für die künftigen
generationen bedeutet dass sie
eigentlich gar
eine privatsphäre haben weil mit dem
internet der dinge
dieses geschäftsmodell ja in unsere
intimsphäre vorrückten
was können wir uns nicht das sehe ich
radikal anders ich glaube dass wir zum
einen die gerade die junge generation
völlig unterschätzen
die sind sehr gut in der lage mit den
werkzeugen umzugehen
meine studentinnen und studenten um es
wieder auf den punkt herunterzubrechen
die verwenden facebook nur mehr um
pressemitteilung sad ich ihren eltern
und großeltern in ihrem freundeskreis
bekannt zu geben wann sie wird eine
tolle leistung im studium erbracht haben
verwenden aber andere methoden die sehr
viel datenschutzfreundlicher sind andere
plattformen um vielleicht die bilder vom
trinkgelage des letzten abends zu
verbreiten
also das heißt hier gibt es also schon
eine ganz klare entwicklung hin zu einem
verständnis von werkzeugen auch
digitaler natur und eine auswahl dieser
werkzeug und vielleicht sind ihre
studenten auch nicht ihn haben nein das
glaube ich nicht aber wenn sie sich
ansehen wie viele in deutschland
janet hat er gesagt dort werde man sehr
datenschutz auf ihn ein recht auf
vergessen haben wollten vor fünf jahren
dann warnt dass etwa 60 prozent wenn sie
in amerika sich die werte ansehen dann
wand es über 84 prozent also hier zu
sagen die deutschen werden jetzt so
datenschutz safina an aber ich habe
sachsen unterschiedliche orientierung
und ja die amerikaner während das nicht
das glaube ich es falsch
ich glaube wir müssen das sehr viel
genauer hinsehen welche dynamiken im
laufen sind
ich stimme völlig zu dass die menschen
wenig vertrauen haben in den datenschutz
aber das liegt vor allem am datenschutz
dem mechanismus des datenschutzes und
weniger an der digitalen feinde lassen
sie uns über diesen mechanismus sprechen
weil sie frau hoffmann haben ja eine
digital carter mit initiiert die die
menschen und bürgerrechte in dieser
digitalen mehr als schützen sorgen nicht
jetzt vor dem start sondern vor diesen
großen kommt
wie sie sagen und im artikel 11 steht da
jeder hat ein recht über seine daten zu
bestimmen
das meint das denn was könnte das
konkret heißen wir kennen ja das prinzip
der informationellen selbstbestimmung
das ist in datenschutz auch im
europäischen datenschutz schon bisher
verankert gewesen und erst mal bedeutet
es dass für unternehmen die unsere daten
verarbeiten immer eine rechtsgrundlage
gegeben sein muss
im prinzip ist die verarbeitung von
daten erst mal verboten das kann man
sich heute so kaum vorstellen
aber das ist tatsächlich das
grundlegende prinzip des datenschutzes
das unternehmen die erlaubnis brauchen
dafür dass sie unsere daten verarbeiten
können darf ich kurz die gebe ich ja
wenn ich auf die agbs einfach so klang
das nicht lese oder das steht alles drin
und das ist das problem dass wir diesen
erlaubnisvorbehalt faktisch so
ritualisiert haben dass das erlauben
jeden jemand dritten zuzugestehen mit
meinen daten bestimmte zwecke zu
verfolgen gar nicht mehr wahrnehmbar ist
sind sie das zustimmungsrecht im
datenschutz ist die freiheit des vogels
im käfig zu singen
und tatsächlich ist es so dass wir alle
auf ok klicken so wie sie es gesagt na
und damit unser recht auf
informationelle selbstbestimmung ausüben
ich habe vor einigen jahren versucht ein
bankkonto in deutschland zu eröffnen
bei einer großen deutschen bank habe die
datenschutzbestimmungen vorgelegt
bekommen habe die bestimmung 3 und 4
rausgestrichen die dame hat mich
angesteckt das mag ich über mein recht
auf informationelle selbstbestimmung hat
sie hat gesagt haben sie kein recht hier
sie können entweder ein konto eröffnen
oder und und unterschreiben oder mein
zimmer zu verlassen
das ist informationelle selbstbestimmung
in der praxis heißt das ich glaube das
ist der käfig das heißt wir müssen in
wirklichkeit einen anderen datenschutz
mechanismus schaffen der die
verantwortlichkeit der daten verwender
bedeutet und nicht darauf abzielt dass
die einzelnen sich gegen die großen
datenkraken zu werden
aber die eu hatte sie ein gesetz in
kraft gesetzt dass er
seine wirkung entfalten wird ein neues
datenschutz grund verordnung ende mai
wird die ihre wirkung entfalten diesen
jahres und da hat man ein recht auf
auskunft über die daten dies hat mir
gesagt herausschauen auf eine kopie habe
ich gelesen auf die löschung sogar
falscher daten und uns drohen glaube ich
millionenstrafen wenn alles nichts neues
hatten wir selbst jahrzehnt also es geht
zu wenig weit würden sie sagen was da
kommt es ist einfach die falsche
richtung ist einfach den käfig vergolden
aber ist sie noch im käfig sie sehen das
anders ich sehe das ein bisschen anders
es ist tatsächlich so dass das meiste
was die europäische datenschutz grund
verordnung bringt ist den akzent stärker
auf die durchsetzung zu legen
es ist im datenschutz tatsächlich so
dass wir ein starkes
durchsetzungsvermögen das heißt
unternehmen haben sich in der regel
nicht an die vorschriften des
datenschutzes gehalten und jetzt werden
sie mit großen strafen bedroht
ich sehe es wie victor dass das
datenschutzrecht sehr stark den akzent
auf das individuum legt und dem
individuum auch die verantwortung für
den umgang mit den daten zuschreibt und
dass diese verantwortung angesichts des
machtgefälles zwischen unternehmen und
individuen sehr und das liegt daran dass
wir das dilemma zwischen ich würde gerne
meine persönlichen daten schützen
ich will aber gleichzeitig diesen dienst
nutzen und vermutlich auch ihn in
personalisierter form nutzen dass dieses
dilemma zu lösen bei uns liegt und da
ist es nicht gut aufgehoben
man braucht eigentlich kollektive
lösungen sehen sich manchmal gerät genau
wir machen das ja auch bei der
lebensmittelkontrolle nicht anders ich
gehe doch als nicht mit meinem
chemielabor in die migros um die
lebensmittel dort zu prüfen ob sie
genießbar sind oder nicht sondern ich
verlasse mich darauf dass es
entsprechende verfahren behörden und
regularien gibt die sicherstellen dass
die migros nur lebensmittel anbietet das
sind
aber auch das haben wir im datenschutz
nur jedoch natürlich wir haben
datenschutzbeauftragte und deren rolle
wird künftig auch gestärkt es ist zum
beispiel so das unternehmen
nach der neuen datenschutz grund
verordnung gehalten sein werden auch
folgen abzuschätzen und stärker explizit
zu machen und was die einzelnen zwecke
sind aber wir haben einen
bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten nach dem
deutschen bundesdatenschutzgesetzes der
kein verfahren einleiten konnte
jahrzehntelang der konnte nur in den
medien einen datenschutz problematik
aber wenn sie drohen sanktionen
am ende aber nur jetzt drohen sanktionen
aber nur sanktionen die einen klaren
verstoß gegen individualrechte bedeuten
aber was ist wenn die individuen sich
nicht zur wehr setzen was ist wenn es
nicht einen max schrems gibt der gegen
facebook vorgeht
und deswegen brauchen wir wie beim
lebensmittelrecht staatliche kontrolle
und regulierung der verwendung der daten
unabhängig davon ob es ein max schrems
gibt oder nicht
also was ich auch so sehe ist dass auch
das neue datenschutzrecht an diesem
prinzip der informelle selbstbestimmung
festhält und dass das dauerhaft keine
gute lösung ist aber es stärkt doch
tatsächlich auch die
datenschutzbeauftragten in den
unternehmen wir werden ganz sicher
stärker zur rechenschaft gezogen als das
bisher der fall war
ich würde aber gerne noch mal auf einen
punkt zurück kommen wo ich widersprechen
möchte und das war der punkt den du
gemacht hast dass die studenten oder die
jungen leute heute das internet als tool
ganz gut zu nutzen wissen und deshalb
auch in der lage sind ihre daten besser
zu schützen also dass wir nicht wie die
schafe alle unsere daten hergeben
ich würde behaupten dass in dem maße in
dem das digitale infrastruktur l wird
also das internet der dinge um sich
greift und faktisch jedes objekt mit dem
wir uns befassen
eine digitale schnittstelle bekommt
diese möglichkeit des strategischen
umgangs immer weniger gegeben ist das
individuum wird künftig nicht mehr in
der lage sein sich digitalen
infrastrukturen zu entziehen
das digitale wird eher sowas wie strom
den wir eigentlich immer ausgesetzt das
ist sie reden von diesem internet der
dinge schon rüber aussehen so andrea
sind wohin vom ausland ist selbst
gespeist werden dann und damit komme ich
jetzt zu meinem punkt damit schwinden
auch die möglichkeiten des individuums
also auf der ebene des einzelnen
stratege staaten freizugeben oder nicht
sondern das wird so sehr alltäglich dass
wir dem faktisch ausgesetzt sind und
auch deshalb bin ich der überzeugung
dass wir im datenschutz eindeutig
nachziehen müssen
die neue verordnung die wir jetzt
bekommen die ist gut weil sie stärker
auf die durchsetzung des rechts pocht
und wir können auch sehen dass
unternehmen nervös werden und sich
darauf einstellen
um diesen strafen zu entgehen aber das
ist ein zwischenschritt wir werden und
dass die charta geht eben ein bisschen
in diese richtung zu sagen
die rechte die wir haben sind gut aber
sie müssen angepasst werden auf das was
da kommen sie und ich finde dass die
rechte schlecht sind und wir eigentlich
das kollektiv ihren müssen den
datenschutz genauso wie in der
lebensmittelkontrolle oder wenn der
fahrzeug sicherheitskontrolle
wir lassen sie auch den airbag nicht
selber überprüfen sondern wir gehen
davon aus dass der 1
durch entsprechende verfahren getestet
und überprüft wird und deshalb ist für
mich ein datenschutz der auf
individuelle rechte abzielt sowie der
vogel im käfig sind jetzt möchte ich
noch einen schritt weiter gehen also und
über diese regulierung entsprechen und
was die über diese politischen
regulierung was die folgen sind für die
innovation und für die wirtschaft und
genau diese frage haben wir auch im
world web forum gestellt inwiefern der
regulierung ein innovations- hindernis
sein kann
wir haben von meinem verständnis in
europa ein defizit wird sind nicht bei
den innovativsten es sind nicht bei den
forschungsstärksten das ist den bernern
osten besser entwickelt das ist in den
usa besser entwickelt
ich werde gelegenheit in brüssel war um
auch unsere schulen anzubieten die
überdurchschnittlich gut sind und
mithelfen können europa einen preis
erhöht zuschalten regulationen können
manchmal die innovationen unterstützen
weil sie investitionen schützen helfen
aber zuviel regulation bremst die
innovation
es braucht also die richtige balance und
eine zielführende absicht wir sind
überzeugt dass regulationen helfen
können um das spielfeld im übergang zum
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
einzugrenzen
insgesamt müssen wir schauen dass europa
bei dem datenschutz themen nicht
benachteiligt wird gegenüber
beispielsweise der usa das genau was sie
sagen und das wiederum aber im
gleichklang bringen mit den interessen
der und und rechten der bürgerinnen und
bürger sehr viele veränderungen gerade
im digitalisierungs bereich des vereins
begeistern das neue und man muss
wirklich auch die menschen mitnehmen
inspirieren aufzeigen wieso gerade diese
sinnfrage warum machen wir jetzt diese
veränderung was bringt uns das was ist
eigentlich die vision diese themen muss
man immer wieder adressieren und auch
mit einer gewissen begeisterung und
freude für die zukunft adressieren und
dann gelingt das auch für ps3 die
menschen von menschen wollen sich
grundsätzlich schon verändern darf das
glaube ich schon aber man muss das ziel
sein und muss den grund sehen wie sich
das auch lohnt
ja diese offenheit gegenüber der zukunft
der digitalisierung die sieht man im
silicon valley sehr stark dieser geist
weht er auch so ein bisschen an diesem
word web forum und die usa insgesamt in
sachen datenschutz weil darüber
gesprochen haben sind ja eher ein
bisschen liberaler als die aus europa
die eu ist dass im globalen wettbewerb
ein problem für die eu und wo hat man da
die balance
es ist ganz sicher ein problem
die unterschiedlichkeit der
der rechtlichen situation aber
andererseits sagen viele unternehmen in
europa auch dass sie auf diese weise
spezielle märkte bedienen können
beispielsweise cloud dienste für
unternehmen die ein großes interesse
daran haben dass sie nicht opfer von
spionage werden und von daher
interessiert sind an europäischen
diensten die sicherstellen können dass
die daten in europa bleiben und nicht in
anderen ländern durch andere länder
fließen
ich finde wir müssen vorsichtig sein
dass wir uns nicht zu stark in die
datenschutzdebatte verbeißen
ich glaube das ist ein wichtiges thema
ich hab da eine relativ schafe meinung
dazu wie ich schon zum ausdrucken gesagt
habe aber ich glaube es ist eben nur
eines der vielen themen und gerade was
den internationalen den globalen
wettbewerb betrifft ist es nur eine
komponente von vielen komponenten
hier zählt auch die kreativität die
originalität die bereitschaft neues zu
riskieren
innerhalb einer volkswirtschaft ob
jemand ein neues startup unternehmen
digitalen gründet und das nächste
facebook werden
das bedeutet auch was investieren wir in
bildung und ausbildung wie gehen wir mit
dieser digitalen neuen welt um und
welche anderen wirtschaftlichen
rahmenbedingungen gibt es steuern
monopol und und wettbewerbs regulierung
in et cetera
wir haben genau diese frage auch
gestellt am world webforum und zwar
bezogen bezogen auf die schweiz weil die
schweiz gilt ja nach dem global
innovation index der die innovation ist
oft aus innovationsfeld meisterin im
globalen vergleich und wir wollten
wissen was wir tun müssen als schweiz
damit das auch in zukunft noch so bleibt
innovation braucht einen gewissen druck
und eine gewisse dringlichkeit und
vielleicht sogar eine gewisse angst dass
wir dort oben bleiben und mein thema ist
immer fast paranoid sind wir nicht zu
selbstzufrieden in diesem land geht uns
zu gut dass sie ein bisschen salopp
gesagt aber es trifft eigentlich den
kern ganz gut und ich glaube wir alle
sollten so ein bisschen im nacken von
uns spüren dass die konkurrenz da ist
das kleine junge länder wie estland
haben wir vorher auf der bühne gesehen
vor zehn jahren nirgends waren und heute
rollenmodelle sie in punkto innovation
und digitalisierung also ich glaube es
braucht eine gewisse paranoia eine
gewisse angst dass wir nicht dort oben
bleiben
ich glaube das ist der beste treiber für
innovationen
ich spreche auf allen internationalen
begegnungen vom la petit papa de la
suisse und für mich steckt hinter dieser
blöcke die parade die idee ganz mutig
ganz offen ganz vorne orientiert wagen
zu wollen und die risiken zu eliminieren
so sobald man sie erkannt hat und das
hat weit geführt
let's continue das prinzip ist also wenn
wir bei der politik sind glaube ich dann
sind wir ganz gut unterwegs wir haben
eine politik in diesem land die in der
regel relativ wirtschaftsliberal ist
auch im umgang mit den digitalen
unternehmen mit startups und so weiter
ein konkretes beispiel ein ein startup
sollte nicht besteuert werden bevor es
wirklich gewinn macht dass ich so ein
ganz kleines aber sehr konkretes
beispiel nur ja nicht den stationen an
die unternehmerschaft herankommen lassen
staat muss auf der seite bleiben schon
rahmens definieren sagte tauss andere
regeln die die kleinen jungen und
junggebliebenen menschen weiblich und
männlich ja sehr liberale stimmen was
halten sie von diesem roten ich bin ein
bisschen überrascht weil selbst aus dem
silicon valley hört man ja inzwischen
viele unten rufe was beispielsweise
künstliche intelligenz und
machine learning anbelangt manche leute
haben die sorge dass die technologien
die wir da entwickeln so mächtig werden
dass sie mächtiger werden als die
menschen die sie entwickelt haben und
dass wir deshalb einen gesetzlichen
rahmen brauchen die diese technik
entwicklung auch zurückbinden an die
menschenrechte die ja demokratien erst
ermöglichen
und ich finde das ist ein sinnvoller
gedanke sie können gerne zu diesen boten
stellung nehmen was die schweiz betrifft
ich bin nicht überrascht ich glaube das
reflektiert den eindruck den offenbar
die interviewten hatten nämlich dass bei
uns in europa zu viele reguliert wird
für mich stellt sich nicht die frage ob
zu viel oder zu wenig reguliert wird
sein ob richtig oder falsch reguliert
wird das ist viel entscheidender
ich meine die eu hat ja in verschiedenen
punkten wirklich durchgegriffen also sie
hat zum beispiel google verklagt für
2,42 milliarden weil sie den wettbewerb
verzerrt haben
margarete vestager die eu wettbewerbs
kommissarin hat da google die die stirn
geboten
google hätte seinen eigenen seine
eigenen produkte ist ein eigenes
preisvergleichsdienst besser platziert
als andere
das ist so eins das andere das problem
mit steuererleichterung in ländern wie
irland oder luxemburg ist apple
aufgefordert 13 milliarden
zurückzuzahlen und soweit also es geht
was man hat schon den eindruck die
politik hat jetzt langsam begriffen was
da passiert absolut zu sehen ist auch
und auch das ist nicht überraschend
das war auch vor 50 und 400 jahren nicht
anders wenn ein problem man eine
gesellschaft heran getragen wird und der
code wird dann versuchen wir in der
regel eine lösung zu finden
das macht die eu und die macht das
eigentlich ganz gut die spannende frage
ist nicht wie lösen wir das problem von
heute oder von gestern
aktionen wie gehen wir die probleme von
morgen an wenn wir heute nicht die
richtigen weichen stellen
künstliche intelligenz schon etwas
angesprochen aber auch digitale mehr
dann haben wir vielleicht nicht nur
einen wettbewerbsnachteil sondern
überhaupt keinen wettbewerb gehen zu
lassen sie uns darüber sprechen
übersetzt diese großen datenmengen big
data das ein riesen erkenntnis
instrument ist sagen sie haupt sowie ein
neues teleskop wo man komplexe phänomene
einfach es endlich mal besser verstehen
kann weil mir genug daten haben und
genug rechenkapazität stehen ist so eine
sache aber auf jeden fall nutzen wir
diese daten um mehr informationen zu
erzeugen es sind korrelationen die dann
herrenlosen erreicht oder so erlauben
und dadurch dass pro eines der probleme
ist dass sich monopole werden das heißt
dass die daten hat nur an diese vier
großen gehen und an einige wenige mehr
und je mehr daten man hat sagen sie
desto innovativer kann man auch sein
dass die bessere produkte kann man auf
den markt bringen können sie das noch
mal erläutern dieses problem der quasi
monopol ja absolut und sehr gerne das
spannende am markt ist dass wir
wettbewerb brauchen am markt der mitte
da der markt auch kompetitiv bleibt
damit angebot und nachfrage gut
zueinander zu einem sinnvollen preis
finden können desto größer unternehmen
werden desto günstiger können sie
herstellen man nennt das skaleneffekte
und die skaleneffekte führen zu markt
konzentrationen unsere hoffnung war dass
wir diese marktkonzentration dadurch
stoppen können das kleine startups tolle
neue ideen innovativ sind
dass die dann den großen die stirne
bieten können und sagen können du kannst
ja billiger produzieren aber ich hab das
bessere produkte und insofern hat die
innovation immer gegen gewirkt der
marktkonzentration in zukunft die
innovation aus den daten kommen und
nicht mehr aus den guten ideen der
menschen
und dann führt die innovation dazu dass
die großen die viele daten haben noch
innovativer werden und günstig
herstellen können und damit haben wir
ein problem der marktkonzentration wir
sie nie zuvor gehabt
die großen kassen hat die kleinen
startup einfach auf das ist asozial und
können damit auch entscheiden ob sie
bestimmte innovationen überhaupt
durchziehen
oder nicht sie können auch kleine
aufkaufen und sagen in diese richtung
gehen wir nicht weil wir haben selber
schon ein produkt das ist ja bei vielen
start ab so dass die gezielt darauf
hinarbeiten vom großen gekauft zu werden
und damit dann auch die frage der
neuerung in den händen von wenigen
unternehmen liegt aber sie hängen
lösungsvorschlag kann ja aber denken sie
nun denken sie nur ein google mit dem
selbst fahrenden auto alle großen
autohersteller haben selbst fördern die
autos zusammen aber relativ wenig
sensoren daten von den selbstfahrenden
autos sollen lernen dass er relativ
langsam
deswegen spart ein durchschnittlicher
selbst fahren das auto eines
autoherstellers
vielleicht 300 kilometer weit bevor man
eingreifen muss ein durchschnittliches
google auto fährt 8000 kilometer weit
bevor man eingreift weil google um den
faktor 100 mehr informationen pro
sekunde sammelt bei den selbstfahrenden
autos unterwegs haben und damit mehr
daten hat um innovativ zu senden
und um diese marktmacht zu brechen
schlagen wir in unserem buch vor das
progressive daten teil die die
progressive daten teilung pflicht das
heißt die pflicht der großen datenkraken
je mehr daten sie haben die daten
anderen auch mitbewerbern zur verfügung
stellen zu müssen eine schöne idee aber
wir setzen wir das um also eigentlich
muss tut das sind es daten steuer oder
sowas so ist es genau man muss ein teil
der daten abgeben aber wie kriegt man
die konzerne dazu dass die das machen ja
doch recht wir kriegen ja auch durch
recht die konzerne dazu dass sie steuern
zahlen eher apple wird er in den
nächsten wochen 13 milliarden überweisen
wenn wir also über rechte es schaffen
dass die den geldbeutel öffnen dann
werden wir über recht auch schaffen dass
sie den zugang zu ihren daten öffnen das
spannende dabei ist wie kann ich wie
kann ich das so strukturieren dass die
großen immer noch innovativ sein können
aber die kleinen von dieser
innovationskraft der daten mit
profitieren können
und das können wir weil daten im
gegensatz zu geld nicht exklusiv sind
wenn ich ihnen meine daten gebe habe ich
die daten trotzdem noch sie profitieren
ich profitiere auch noch anders bei geld
wenn ich ihnen mein geld gibt habe ich
keine
geld mehr daten kann man kopieren
weitergeben und sie verlieren nicht an
wert so sagen na ja es kommt schon
darauf manche daten verlieren an wert
wenn man sie nicht mehr exklusiv hat das
kommt auch auf den typ der daten an
aber das interessante bei daten ist ja
dass die eigentlich rechtlich nicht
geschützt sind daten gehören im grunde
niemanden unternehmen können natürlich
investitionsschutz für daten geltend
machen
aber auch im datenschutzrecht ist es ja
so dass ich ein auskunftsrecht habe
darüber was unternehmen über mich
gesammelt haben die da wollte dort
eigentlich mir gehören risiken auch
nicht daten ist generell die sind nichts
gehirn dem sinne nicht schutzfähig es
sei denn man macht irgendwas dritten
drittes geld wie ich habe in diese
dienstleistung sehr viel geld investiert
und deshalb also solche argumente muss
man machen aber daten als solche sind
gar nicht schutzfähig sie fallen
beispielsweise licht und das urheber-
oder patentschutz recht
aber wem gehören sie dagegen der sie
sozusagen sammelt von mir oder der sie
verwertet das ist eine der radweg ist
eine der offenen regulatorischen fragen
die wir in zukunft klären müssen
die eu bewegt sich in so eine richtung
die europäische kommission denkt darüber
nach und ich bin an der stelle victors
meinung dass wir uns keinen gefallen tun
wenn wir die monopolisierung tendenzen
die in der daten generierung angelegt
sind wenn wir die rechtlich auch noch
absichern wir müssen eigentlich das
gegenteil machen ein ganz genau das
schlimmste was wir tun könnten wäre
europaweit ein eigentumsrecht an den
daten zu verankern denn das würde nur
die mächtigen die ohnehin schon sehr
viel daten haben weiter stärken
wir haben das im urheberrecht gesehen
das hat nicht den autorinnen und autoren
geholfen sondern hat in wirklichkeit den
rechteinhaber rinnen und inhabern
geholfen
vor einigen jahren gab es die statistik
dass nur zweieinhalb prozent der
gesamten einnahmen aus kreativen gütern
in deutschland tatsächlich den autoren
in der natur in zukunft zu fließen
dann haben wir aber einen
unglaublich in effizienten mechanismus
geschaffen und diesen mechanismus
brauchen wir bei den daten nicht noch zu
kopieren jetzt sind wir schon so ein
bisschen bei den bei den steilen thesen
auch dieses buches das sie zusammen mit
thomas ramge den journalisten
geschrieben haben das eine ist dass
dieser vorschlag der der der daten
steuer
das andere ist dass sie sagen durch
diesen daten kapitalismus wie sie das
nennen wird das geld unwichtiger und die
firmen oder unternehmen werde nun
wichtiger
können sie diesen gedanken kurz
erläutern dass ich den verstehe
ganz klar das geld das relativ einfach
am markt erfüllt geld eine wichtige
rolle ich zahle am markt mit geld aber
dass gelder fühlt noch eine zweite
wichtige rolle am markt ist informiert
mich über die präferenzen und vorleben
über das angebot was am markt vorhanden
ist über den drei tage lang über die
nachfrage über den preis könnte wie viel
jemand haben will für ein produkt wie
viel jemand bereit ist zu zahlen
das hat der friedrich hayek der berühmte
wirtschaftswissenschaftler schon gesagt
das wird in den preis kondensiert und
über den preis und damit über geld
kommunizieren wir informieren wir uns am
markt
das hat einigermaßen gut funktioniert
aber da gehen viele details sollen in
zukunft werden wir uns mit daten
informieren am markt und nicht nur über
den bremer als er umkreist das heißt das
wer wird die angebote dieser markt gibt
nicht nur mit dem preis versuchen sie zu
vergleichen sondern über viele andere
dimensionen stellen sie sich vor sie sie
brauchen eine urlaubsreise dann kaufen
sie nicht mehr nur die günstigste zum
richtigen datum sondern sie schauen sich
heute über die buchungsplattformen an
wie gut das hotel ist welche fotos sie
sehen von den leuten die tatsächlich
dort waren welche bewertungen es gibt
etc
tripadvisor zum beispiel eine reise
avocado und oder amazon bei amazon oder
erfahren oder kayak oder blah blah calvo
es einen mitfahrer auswählen können
nicht nur wie viel der zahlt wenn er mit
ihnen im auto mitfährt sondern auch je
nachdem wie viel er spricht oder ständig
eine plaudertasche ist blabla oder aber
er schmeckt bla je nachdem was ich wie
meine prinz
und damit wird am markt über diese daten
ein besseres pass verhältnis eine
bessere passgenau ich hätte schon ein
angebot und nachfrage dafür aber geld
verliert damit seine informationelle
rolle uns zu informieren welche daten
diese rolle übernehmen
klingt nach einem großen fortschritt
irgendwie erster markt effizienter wird
dass ich meine individuellen bedürfnisse
besser befriedigen kann
sehen sie das ähnlich also wenn ich
jetzt mal aus der praxis sprechen soll
ich suche neues produkt und gucke was
dritte über dieses produkt gesagt haben
stelle ich fest dass ich dann darüber
nachdenken muss ob ich diesen anderen
käufer trauer
da kommen immer mehr meter schleifen
dazu die mich nach einer gewissen zeit
einfach überfordern
wir wissen auch dass diese art von
bewertungssystem ihre eigenen
pathologien hervorbringen nämlich
dergestalt dass leute sich wechselseitig
die qualität absprechen also dass
strategisches verhalten eintritt was
dazu führt dass man selber den stimmen
der anderen möglicherweise gar nicht
mehr trauen kann das leider diese
information kurz gesagt diese
informationen sind ja nicht objektiv
sondern die verkörpern auch immer eine
bestimmte perspektive hatte ich zb krach
mit meinem ehepartner und bewährte
deshalb diesen urlaubsort schlechter als
sie sonst getan hätte et cetera et
cetera
man braucht wiederum informationen um
die die die qualität der information die
man bekommt tatsächlich ein ordentliches
begründungen und da sowas so komplex
dass ein dass unter umständen wirklich
überfordert
da stimme ich ganz zu natürlich kann uns
das überfordern
wobei ich ganz grundsätzlich schon sagen
muss mehr information ist immer besser
als weniger information wissen ist
besser sind nur die komplexe aber in der
schlecht hier an aber ich möchte schon
auf den punkt nachkommen wie wir als
menschen jetzt über diese kognitive
hürde janet nur auf die richtige weise
hingewiesen hat
wegkommen deswegen sehen wir ganz
besonders und beschreiben das auch in
unserem buch so den eine rolle für
sogenannte matching algorithmen also
verfahren um angebot und nachfrage gut
miteinander entdeckung zu bringen und
über digitale assistenten die besser
verstehen welche präferenzen und welche
informationen es am markt gibt
das gibt sie in einzelnen ansätzen schon
aber dass mehr information hilfreicher
ist das kann ich schon daran ablesen
dass ich mich erinnere wie meine eltern
als ich noch ein kind war
urlaube ausgesucht haben hier haben wir
aus dem katalog einen urlaub ausgesucht
haben gehofft dass die bilder nicht
allzu stark lügen und wenn wir
hingefahren sind das war keine
katastrophe sind das nächste jahr wieder
hingefahren weil das risiko zu hoch
waren dass wir was neues ausprobieren
ich suche heute meine hotel sehr viel
genau das problem ist dass wir immer
gläserner werden dadurch oder also wenn
ich diese probleme ist diese produkte
nutzen möchte dann muss ich einfach
allgemeinen daten preisgeben die müssen
mich kennen erst dann können ein
optimales angebot von entschuldigen sie
bitte aber nicht die müssen sie kennen
sie müssen sich kennen und die digitale
assistenten die für sie arbeiten müssen
sie kennen das problem dass wir heute
mit dieser plattform ökonomie haben ist
dass die digitalen assistenten die wir
verwenden gleichzeitig jene assistenten
sind die uns etwas verkaufen wollen
aber in zukunft werden wird die
digitalen assistenten unabhängig vom
verkäufer sehen es gibt keinen grund
theoretisch warum der digitale assistent
immer nur im säckel des verkäufers tätig
sind der grund ist das geld nein hat der
grund sind die daten und wenn wir den
daten den digitalen assistenten die
unabhängig sind zur verfügung stellen
dann kann dieser digitale assistent uns
besser und objektiver beraten als
derjenige von amazon drauf man teilt
diesen optimismus ich glaube dass dieses
dilemma dass dienstleistungen die an
qualität gewinnen wenn sie sich auf uns
als individuen ausrichten
gleichzeitig sehr viel informationen
über uns sammeln müssen und wir damit
die kontrolle über unsere informationen
über
das was wir kommunizieren wollen über
uns verlieren und damit auch eine
gewisse macht an dritte geben
diesem dilemma werden wir nicht
entkommen jedenfalls sehe ich im moment
keine gute lösung dafür
und es ist tatsächlich ein dilemma weil
ja personenbezogene dienste einen
unheimlichen wohlfahrts effekt haben
jeder der mal eine suchmaschine wie
google benutzt hat von dem gerät das
einem nicht kennt wird schockiert sein
oder dass man noch nicht benutzt hat
sagen wer das smartphone von jemand
dritten oder am anderen computer wird
schockiert sein über die wir die
streubreite der ergebnisse die man
bekommt es ist tatsächlich so dass auch
hinter unserem rücken ohne dass wir das
im einzelnen wahrnehmen digitale dienste
immer stärker auf uns also auf unsere
eigene sucht historie auf unser eigenes
verhalten der vergangenen jahre sich
einstellen und immer passgenauer liefern
und wenn wir das ausschalten was wir tun
können sehen wir wie stark wir davon
profitieren
aber wie wir die andere seite davon dass
wir trotzdem souverän als individuen
bleiben wollen in dem sinne dass wir
auch steuern können möchten was jemand
drittes über uns weiß wie wir mit diesem
dilemma umgehen sollen in zukunft da
habe ich keine antwort darauf und und
die zukunft muss deshalb seien die
digitalen intermediäre aus den fängen
der datenkraken auszulösen
wir brauchen also in diesen die in
diesen digitalen kapitalismus märkte in
denen ist informationelle
zwischenhändler gm ist allein gibt das
ist aber auch nicht der staat sondern
ein
sie sind unternehmen das sind
unternehmen die für mich arbeiten aber
die sind doch sehr mit dem tippen mit
dem gleichen geschäftsmodell das wir
ohnehin in vielerlei hinsicht haben
denken sie an das kuratierte shoppen
denken sie an jemanden der ihnen hilft
beim einkaufen dann arbeitet er auch
nicht fürs kaufhaus sondern sie stellen
den ein und sagen hilf mir und geh mit
mir einkaufen und der somit keine daten
natürlich sei man ja auch daten aber da
gibt es viele davon
und dass das problem ist ja nicht das
datensammeln
problem ist dass nur wenige alle daten
sammeln wenn das datensammeln sehr viel
dezentraler passiert wenn es viele
unterschiedliche angebote gibt wenn es
eine diversität der der berater gibt mit
denen ich shoppen ging dann hat keiner
der berater für sich selbst die absolute
allmacht sowie war aber trotzdem haben
wir ja eine zirkulation von daten und
das kann man selbst wenn man große
unternehmen zwingt dazu wie ihr das
vorschlag diese daten zu teilen heißt es
ja nicht dass diese daten deshalb nicht
mehr zirkulieren im gegenteil sie
zirkulieren er mehr und technik wie wir
sie heute erleben nämlich die
profilbildung die daraus besteht dass
man von unterschiedlichen quellen daten
zusammenfügt und dann aussagen darüber
treffen kann was jeder von uns künftig
wahrscheinlich tun wird oder nicht tun
wird diese möglichkeiten steigen ja eher
nein weil wir in unserem vorschlag ganz
klar machen dass wir bei der daten
teilung pflicht die daten behandeln
müssen das heißt anonymisieren müssen
oder pseudonymisiert müssen und dieses
zusammen schauen funktioniert nur dann
wenn ich über verschiedene
identifikationsmerkmale unterschiedliche
datensätze zusammenführen können
darf ich da noch kurz ein haken und
davon problem hinweisen dass das ja
nicht nur diese firmen insofern mächtig
sind als sie geld machen sondern auch
politischen einfluss geltend machen
können zum beispiel also wenn donald
trump 80 prozent des werbebudgets in
facebook anzeigen investierte
also wir können nicht nur passgenaue
werbung zu schalten sondern auch
politische kampagnen microsites micro
targeting heißt das genau
was machen wir dagegen oder ist das gut
zumindest da passiert also erstmal micro
targeting sieht man in ländern mit
liberaleren datenschutz als das in
content kontinentaleuropa der fall ist
wir haben in den wahlkämpfen in
frankreich in österreich in deutschland
diese art des daten sammeln wie wir das
aus den
erkennen nicht gesehen dazu muss man
wissen dass die wahlkämpfer in den usa
sogar auf die wahlregister zugreifen
können und damit sehen können wer hat
das letzte mal gewählt wer hat sich für
die vorwahlen registriert wer hat welche
partei unterstützt
diese art von daten die ligen in europa
gar nicht vor
deshalb kann auch diese art von einfluss
nicht ausgeübt werden
es ist auch zumindest haben dass
befragungen der deutschen parteien
ergeben
bei den deutschen parteien nicht
vorgekommen dass sie bald facebook
großartig eingekauft haben nutzerprofile
aber was sie tun können sind so genannte
dark es zu schalten
das heißt dass man und das ist in
england sehr verbreitet passiert dass
man nicht öffentlich war werbung macht
wie wir die von plakaten kennen oder
zeitungsanzeigen sondern dass man
gezielt nutzer von facebook mit werbe
informationen versorgt was aber dritte
nicht sehen und damit wird der wahlkampf
etwas den die öffentlichkeit also
faktisch der sauerstoff entzogen wird
das was wir als öffentliche diskussion
kennen wird plötzlich verengt auf ein
zwiegespräch das intransparent ist
zwischen dem der eine politische werbung
schaltet und dem der sie bekommt und wir
brauchen so was das ist wenn man so will
ein neues politisches instrument die
daten spende von leuten die gegenstand
solcher wahlwerbung solcher dax geworden
sind damit wir überhaupt sehen können
was parteien für messages für kampagnen
eigentlich entwickeln und gleichzeitig
würde ich davor warnen dass wir den
micro targeting die schultern den
populistischen bewegungen in den
vereinigten staaten in die schuhe
schieben wollen wenn wir sie anschauen
schon etwas erwähnt die länder die
weniger micro targeting gesehen haben
frankreich deutschland und österreich
wir haben in frankreich marie le pen wir
haben in deutschland die afg es die
größte oppositionspartei und wir haben
in österreich
die fpö in der bundesregierung als
koalitionspartner
also dort hat auch die beschränkung des
micro targeting nicht dazu geführt dass
die populistischen parteien sich jetzt
ihre wähler suchen müssen
ganz im gegenteil ich glaube es wäre
falsch zu glauben dass es irgendwo eine
technologische brücke gibt mit der wir
die schwierigkeiten des wandels und der
gestaltung des wandels die unsere
gesellschaften heute haben bewältigen
können
das geht nicht so einfach diesen wandel
auch in die digitale welt zu gestalten
für eine gesellschaft bedeutet umbruch
bedeutet veränderung und das bedeutet
gesprächsstoff und das bedeutet
gesprächs und diskussionslos wendigkeit
und nicht eine technologische oder
rechtliche krücke wir sind schon fast am
ende der zeit aber nicht am ende der
diskussion ich könnte noch lange weiter
diskutiert am schluss eine kurze
prognose von ihnen das würde mich
interessieren von diesen großen vier die
wir gesehen haben am anfang
wer wird denn das rennen machen und die
konkurrenz hinter sich lassen in den
nächsten jahren also ich würde mal sagen
was wir an der diskussion im moment
nicht gut sehen können ist wie fragil
sich diese unternehmen alle fühlen
sie stehen in einem harten wettbewerb
gegeneinander
sie versuchen alle so was wie große
gärten ab zu einzuzäunen in die sie alle
nutzer reinpacken so dass die nicht zur
konkurrenz gehen aber keiner von denen
wird langfristig die rolle annehmen die
er jetzt hat herman schönberger larry
page google weiß wie er mit daten umgeht
vielen dank für dieses klare votum und
für die sehr anregende diskussion war
hoffmann herr mayer schönberger ja ob
profilbild essen oder hotel heute wird
so ziemlich alles bewertet der
philosophische stammtisch widmet sich am
17 februar dem thema rating gesellschaft
und sie können mit dabei sein im lokal
sud in basel
melden sie sich doch jetzt auf unserer
webseite an und sichern sie sich ein
ticket und jetzt gleich folgt in der
sternstunde kunden
ein porträt über die schweizer kinoszene
die trotz bescheidener mittel viele
stars hervorgebracht hat wie etwa jean
luc godard oder bruno ganz davor aber
noch ein kleiner denkanstoß in form
eines animationsfilms unserer reihe viel
los so fix über die frage ob uns der
erfolg eigentlich immer recht genießen
sie den sonntag
[Musik]